i'm really excited to share with you
some research that we've been doing in
our refinement enrichment and
advancements laboratory
um here at the university of michigan
and i'll be presenting some research
results
that were conducted by myself as well as
dr vanessa oliver
assessing post-op pain and mice is
really critical for being able to
provide optimal clinical care and
welfare for the animals in our charge
as well as the translation of those
results to our human patients
but it can be exceptionally challenging
there are prey species and so they have
a natural drive to suppress pain
behaviors especially in the presence of
observers
and we have limited time to assess a
large number of animals in our riveria
so what should be assessed for when
we're trying to detect if pain is
present
in our rodent species there's two
general areas we can look for
presence of new pain behaviors and these
are good because they're pain specific
but they tend to be a little less
obvious we can also look for loss of
normal behaviors these are a lot more
obvious and easier to observe
but have the potential to be less pain
specific
as our first new pain behavior let's
look at grima scales grima scales first
came on the scene in around 2010 with
the mouse grimace scale
and have since developed into the rat
rabbit and some large animal species
like horses and pigs
they've been found and validated to be
able to detect post-operative pain
and alleviations of pain with various
analgesics however they can be
challenging to use in rhodes cage side
for example mouse grima scale has been
shown to be significantly lowered
when it scored cage side versus a video
score that's taken
with the person outside of the room so
this was a publication that recently
came out from
university of newcastle and plus one
where they looked at mean grimace scale
scores as they were applied by a caged
side observer
versus taken from a photo in which the
human wasn't in the room
and we see differences between different
strains c57
c3h cd1 valve c and also very
differently between
live scores versus photo scores
another new pain behavior we could look
for is ethograms or changes in behavior
in our lab in the refinement lab we
looked at new ways to assess guinea pig
pain
um so we looked at post castration
guinea pigs
either just after isoflorin anesthesia
or after the isofluorine anesthesia plus
the castration surgery
and we were able to see specific pain uh
influenced
behavioral differences after surgery is
compared to after anesthesia
however when we tried this cage side
versus video scoring when the observer
was out of the room we saw significant
differences in our scoring
so as you can see from this graph which
was published over the summer
in jlass you'll see that the mean
frequency the behaviors was
significantly suppressed
at all time points when it was scored
cage side versus
by remote video so what about cage size
measures of normal loss of normal
behavior again these tend to be a little
bit more obvious
we refer to them as proxy indicators or
visual cues that indicate what
activities animals have been engaged in
or in this case
not engaged in well not in the presence
of an observer
one caveat of these have the potential
to be influenced by
a multitude of factors uh including pain
but also potentially illness like
fever nausea or even phenotype
so how do we conceptualize loss of
normal behaviors i think the easiest way
to
start is by thinking maslow so if we
think about maslow's hierarchy of need
animals might have eating drinking
potentially grooming
at the bottom of their hierarchy of
needs and if these are met they can then
move on to some higher orders like
social
interactions sleeping with cohorts
playing taking treats maybe running on a
wheel
and maybe at the top we might think of
this for humans to be engaging in art or
music for animals it might be
engaging in organization of their cage
space making a really great nest
and as animals are in pain they start to
lose these behaviors in the opposite
order
so the very first behaviors that will
disappear are things like nesting
or at the bottom of the pyramid where we
see them not eating and grooming
this is when we start to recognize loss
and body weight
dehydration or an unkept hair coat
appearance so we really want to be able
to identify pain at the top of that
pyramid here's where a loss of
consumptive behaviors come into play so
this was a graph from a flecknell paper
in 1999
where we see decreases in body weight
which come along with a decrease in food
and water consumption
if they've had surgery without
analgesics
and again we want to recognize pain at
an earlier part of the pyramid so how do
we get up to that top
tier one idea is cage organizations this
is an heiress paper from 2007
where they saw that nest complexity and
cage organization after surgery was
significantly reduced
but they could restore some of those
behaviors by applying appropriate
analgesia in this case
nsaids so the mouse on the right has a
very disorganized cage
the mouse on the left had appropriate
analgesian has this behavior restored
next complex next complexity is also
a common measure that can be used for
loss of a normal behavior
this paper was published in 2013 has a
score of zero to five
from no use of nesting material which is
the score of zero and the untouched
nestlet
all the way up to five where they fully
shredded the nestlet and made a nice
cupped nest out of it um they found
with this scoring system that nine hours
after surgery
less than ten percent of the mice have
manipulated their nesting compared to
seventy for five percent of them
at baseline so this was something they
could easily see a difference in that
was
obvious cage side and they found that
with anesthesia only the condition
decreased nesting um but less though in
surgery so the data is here
and we can see their nest scores on the
y-axis and if they had surgery their
before score
just the light gray is quite high it's
around two after score was completely
absent they didn't have any nests
to score if they had anesthesia only the
effects of having anesthesia
significantly reduce their nest score
but not nearly as much as if they had
had the surgery
and you can see that if they have
surgery with appropriate analgesia
it's about the same as if they never had
surgery at all which really is the goal
tin score was a further evolution of
this concept 100
of healthy mice nine different strains
would retrieve a bit of nesting material
and incorporate it back into their nest
within 10 minutes and they found that
the likelihood of failing a tint test
was much higher after surgery and this
was published by rock it all in 2014
and in fact there's a really great joe
video so if you want to learn about tint
scores or how to score a nest complexity
i'd highly recommend this article for a
tutorial
zone clearance test was the next step in
evolution for
nest consolidation behavior they made
this a more titratable score it was
published in the journal of pain in 2015
where there's six different possible
areas that the mice can clear their
nesting material from
and after 100 minutes they've reliably
cleared all of those zones
and consolidated the nesting material
into one corner so to see a live score
of what this would look like at baseline
there's six pieces of nesting material
in the corner
and after 100 minutes the mouse has
successfully retrieved all those pieces
and made a little nest out of it
after they underwent a painful stimuli
which in this case was acetic acid
they didn't consolidate any of those
pieces but if they
treated them with an analgesic in this
case ketoprofen they were able to mainly
restore that behavior
so using proxy indicators we tried to
utilize all these various types of
methods in a post-op setting with mice
and we found it a little bit difficult
for the purpose of
testing analgesics analysis efficacy
because the nest quality was a bit
subjective and we found it hard to
standardize between different viewers
the zone clearance test was challenging
because the mice would
rarely decide to build a nest perfectly
in the corner and sometimes would build
in the middle of the cage
and then we weren't sure how to score
how many zones had been cleared
and then we loved the tint test but it
was binary and we really needed
something that was a little more
titratable and had
more variation in the scores so we could
tease apart differences between
different analgesics
and their ability to alleviate pain and
mice
so we decided to leverage some natural
behaviors and we looked at nesting
behavior as something that could be
objective
titratable but we also needed to test
where the nest could be built anywhere
in the cage
we also thought about grooming behavior
we knew subjectively in evaluating mice
after surgery that if they had
eye lubrication those that seemed to be
doing poorly would still have really
greasy eyes the next day and weren't
grooming appropriately and so we thought
this is a really highly patterned
behavior it's reproducible
perhaps we can leverage incomplete
grooming from pain as a way to have a
scoring system
so our first step was to look for
products already available one of which
is glow germ
so we chose the orange formulation which
is suspended in mineral oil
it's something normally is to teach kids
how to wash hands so kids apply it to
their hands
wash their hands and then show it under
a black light and if there's any blow
drum left you'll get this
glowing blue signal we then applied a
little bit of it to the top of the
mouse's head about eight microliters and
watched how well they would groom it so
because we know they're always going to
groom in the same pattern it would
reliably
be distributed onto their bodies or
transferred onto their bodies in a very
specific way
so after putting it on their head the
very first place it's going to go
is on to their paws next we'd see it on
their back paws
then they're starting to get it onto
their ears and eventually onto their
nesting material as they manipulate
nesting material in their environment
as they continue to groom it'll start to
come off in the opposite order
so we'll start to lose it in one of
these locations five through two
then only trace amounts will be found at
the original application site where the
concentration was highest
and finally no glider drum signal
observed at all this is an example what
the live score looks like so
the mice in these pictures are
anesthetized just because photographing
the signal
under black light is really challenging
on moving animals so these guys were
under isoflorin anesthesia
so you can see where it was applied
initially where it was transferred to
the toenails it sort of looks like
orange painted toenails on the
for four nails and high nails this is
what it looks like as they try to
groom it over onto their ears and onto
the fringes of the nesting material as
they hold it and pull it and make
a full nest then the
signal starts to go away so here you can
see they only have a little bit
of glow drum signal on their toes and on
top of their heads
and then finally only a trace amount at
their heads or the application site
and then finally when it's gone away
completely and we assessed this in
baseline mice a mix of c57 males and
females
and we found that after an hour they
were already having a score of four
and by 24 hours had reached the maximal
score of completely grooming it off
we then uh partnered with a lab that was
doing ibc ligation as part of a deep
vein thrombosis model
and we assessed the grooming transfer
after anesthesia which was isofluorine
as well as after surgery
so in this graph we see their highest
grooming score achieved at various time
points between 1 and 48 hours
the anesthesia line is in blue so that
was their score after isoflorin only
and the red was after the ibc ligation
surgery
and we can see oops at all time points
uh
1 through 48 there was a significant
delay in
grooming transfer after surgery as
compared to after anesthesia
so we know that this was attributable to
unalleviated pain
next we moved on to a nest consolidation
test or nct
where we sort of built upon the already
published uh
methods with the goal of being able to
build uh the mice being able to build
the nest anywhere in the cage
so here we have a nestlet that we rip up
into four pieces we put one in each
corner
and then we defined nest consolidation
by moving those pieces to within a two
and a half by three and a half inch area
of one another
with a score of zero uh through four to
consolidate
so here's zero score when none of the
pieces are near each other
a score of one when two of the pieces
have moved closely together
a score of two of three of the pieces
has been consolidated score of three of
all the pieces have been consolidated
and then a score of four if they had a
fully formed shredded nest
again we applied this to some animals
that
were just a mix of c57 males and females
adults um
and as before after just one hour they
had already achieved a score of between
two and three and by 24 hours had
achieved the highest score then again we
evaluated the mice in the ivc study
both after anastasia and after surgery
and we saw that
the highest nest consolidation uh
scores were achieved um much higher or
more sooner after anesthesia
so just after eight hours whereas after
surgery
it took them about 35 hours so here we
do see a small effect from the
isofluorine anesthesia
but the surgery really is the larger
driver so we know that
unalleviated pain was the source of the
difference in that signal
okay so just to pull this all together
these are scores at baseline and after
anesthesia only
at one hour so you can see if they had
had
just baseline they had a score of five
or two for nesting after anesthesia
slight delay in the glow germ but no
delay in nesting material
at the same time point after surgery one
hour after surgery you can see the
scores were significantly different
and so there was very obvious visual
delay in both nest consolidation and
grooming transfer
at 24 hours the mice at baseline and
after anesthesia
had it all achieved their maximal scores
but we still had significant delays in
the animals after anesthesia
after surgery so scores of four and two
so they were at
where the animals were after just one
hour after anesthesia
24 hours after surgery and then at 48
hours
we can see the nest consolidation uh
behavior had totally caught up
in the post-surgical animals but we
still had a delay in animals that um
were doing grooming transfers so still a
score of six
we then wanted to expand these tests to
make sure that before we recommended
them
they would work in the wide variety of
situations that you find in your
standard wife area so
we wanted to know will this work just as
well in males as in females
in an inbred as well as outbreads we
looked at c-57s and cd1s
with various types of housing so are
they already have an existing nest
are they socially housed and we wanted
to see
the various effects of different
analgesics on our tests so we had
control animals were just injected with
saline
and then various analgesic treatments
ranging from buprenorphine at 0.1 meg
per kg
sub q every 12 hours for 48 hours
including a preemptive dose
carprophen we actually put into the
drinking water at 30 mix per cake
they got that drinking water bottle
about 24 hours before
surgery and they continued that for an
additional 48 hours after surgery
and then multimodal was the combination
of the two
study design we studied the same animals
under different conditions so we could
control for
inter inter-individual variability so
baseline
after anesthesia and analgesia so that
would allow us to quantify the effects
of the anesthetic and analgesic drugs on
our assessments
and then after a seven day washout to
make sure there was no lasting effects
of the analgesics or anesthetics
they would then undergo the surgery with
the same anesthetics and analgesics
and in this case the surgery was a
simple laparotomy
the pain was then assessed at each of
these time points
2 through 48 hours after the baseline
anesthesia analgesia and surgery
conditions
for assessments of post-operative pain
we wanted to anchor our novel
assessments with some of the more
traditional measures so
um clinically we often recognize
unalieated pain in the terms of weight
loss so they had body weight checks
we then did our grooming transfer and
nest consolidation tests as well as
more of the gold standard mechanical
thresholds with electric bond fray
we also have locomotor activity and so
neural neuroanalytical has a tablet
system called mouse trap where you can
put the mouse on a touchpad
tablet and it will count how many steps
are taken how fast they walk things like
that
and so we also used ambulatory
parameters
here we have our nesting consolidation
test with scores one through five
and we also needed to adjust the scoring
system if they were going to have an
existing nest
so the standard nesting material at the
university of michigan is an enviro pack
so that's
a tea bag like material that holds about
six grams of
shredded paper and so to make this
scoring system work instead of putting
the nestlet pieces
in the four corners we put the nesting
material on the opposite
end of the nestlet and counted
consolidation to be within one
inch of the enviro pack and then fully
integrated into the nest
this is what the images look like for
glow drum transfer
in the c57s and then the cd1s
so you can see um this had a score of
one through five so we tried to simplify
it a little bit for
ease of caged side use so one is that
there's a strong fluorescent signal at
the site of application
two is that it's then gone to either the
front or the rear nails because it can
be kind of hard to
see the nails as they walk around the
cage so being able to see both the front
or the back for that score
helped make it a little easier to use
then looking at the application
of the glow germ to the ears through
grooming
and then finally having it slowly
groomed off so for a losing signal
at those sites and then five having glow
germ no longer detectable
so for validation this is our nest
consolidation
score of the animals at baseline after
anesthesia and surgery at our various
time points
the black line represents baseline the
gray line represents after anesthesia
and logisia
and the red is after surgery so these
are all of our analgesic groups
collapsed
and here we see that there was a slight
delay at the first time 0.2 hours
between baseline and anesthesia and
that's indicated by the hash sign there
the stars indicate that there was a
delay from surgery and so we can see a
delay
in nest consolidation as a result of
surgery for at least the first 12 hours
and again this is for a laparotomy
next we look at our grooming transfer
scores so we see our max grooming
transfer score
on the y-axis and again baseline and
black anesthesia analgesia and gray and
random surgery
um here we saw a much greater effect of
the drugs
on the behavior for grooming so we saw
some delays after anesthesia logisia as
compared to baseline out through 24
hours
however if you look at the black and
gray lines they're much closer together
than you would say say the black or the
gray line from the red lines the red
line is surgery
and we have significant delays after
surgery and grooming transfer
all the way out through 48 hours
we found this um test to be usable in
both males and females so here you see
nest consolidation score
female mice on the left male mice on the
right and in both cases
they had delays and their nest
consolidation score after surgery
um in hours two through eight and then
it had normalized by twelve
when we looked at grooming transfer
source uh in both cases we had
delays and grooming transfer um at the
latter town points about 12 hours
through 48 hours
interestingly the female mice had a few
more time points where they had
significant delays
um as a result of surgery as compared to
the males
and this kind of lines up with
literature in terms of male and female
differences with pain
acute pain for pain effects uh surgery
minus uh versus anesthesia analgesia for
all of the measures that we took
um with the females we saw decreases in
nest consolidation grooming transfer
and at the one time point four hours we
saw differences with mechanical
thresholds
but we found no differences in females
between anesthesia and surgery
with body weight or locomotor activity
and this is important especially if
you're studying pain
um that the nesting and grooming tests
were actually more sensitive than some
of these more standard measures that
we rely on when we're assessing pain in
these species
with the males we saw a decrease in body
weight at 48 hours
um and very similar differences with
nest consolidation and grooming transfer
no differences uh with surgery with
mechanical thresholds or locomotor
activity
moving on to our inbred and outbreak the
cd1s
had decreases in nest consolidation
scores at our first two time points
and c57s for the first three when it
came to grooming transfer again we saw
more of these differences on
the later time points than we did the
earlier so
um 12 through 48 for the cd1s and c-57s
had the additional time points of two
and eight hours
where surgery uh suppressed their return
to a normal grooming transfer
taking together with all the assessments
that we looked at the c-57s
had decreases in body weight at 24 and
48 hours
and nesting consolidation two through
eight grooming transfer out through 48
hours
and one time point at which mechanical
threshold was decreased
with our cd1s we saw fewer differences
only two time points for nest
consolidation
a few time points for grooming transfer
and no differences
with surgery in terms of body weight
mechanical threshold or locomotor
activity
so again more sensitive measures for
nest consolidation and grooming transfer
than some of our more typical measures
moving on to different types of housing
considerations so
singly housed versus pear house for
nesting on the left you see
singly housed mice and it you can see a
significant delay in return to normal
nest consolidation behavior up through
the first 12 hours after surgery for
pear housed animals it was really only
the first time point
and this makes sense because if there's
two animals working together to make a
nest
they're able to um collaborate and have
that nest come together a lot faster
than if a single animal is working on it
by themselves so
this let us know that nest consolidation
test works best for singly housed
animals
and less so for socially housed animals
happily we were able to see with
grooming transfer that it was equally
usable
whether the animals were singly or
socially housed we had been a little
concerned with aloe grooming that they
might groom off each other's
low germ and that they might reach a
higher score faster but that actually
wasn't the case
and even when we used two different
color glow germs to assess
we didn't see any transfer of one
mouse's blow drum to another mouse
as a result of aloe grooming so um here
we see singly housed mice had an
additional time point
at which um their pain was suppressing
grooming transfer
as compared to the pearhouse mice so
potentially a social buffering effect or
analgesic effect from
being socially housed uh
finally we looked at nest consolidation
whether or not they had had as
an existing nest meaning that enviro
pack that was
uh placed on the left-hand side and um
we were able to see that uh whether or
not they had had an
existing nest or were starting from
scratch the nest consolidation scores
were reliably
decreased or delayed after surgery for
the first 12 hours
so we're really happy that the animals
could both be socially housed and
have nesting and be able to use a
combination of these assessments
if you look at grooming transfer scores
with them without a nest again we were
able to reliably see
decreases with um our nest or our
grooming transfer scores for about uh
the first
48 hours with the dropout around four to
eight hours
depending all right so taken together
with all of our assessments
we see that pear housed animals have a
decrease in body weight
mechanical thresholds and local motor
activity less so than we see changes
with nest consolidation or grooming
transfer
so here's the pair housed tingly housed
and ness consolidation
so for a discussion we were happy to see
that nest consolidation
was better at identifying pain at
earlier time points because this gives
you a sense
right after surgery how they're doing in
those first 12 hours interestingly
grooming transfer was a little bit
better at detecting pain
at later time points as well as more
time points
um and this was really interesting we're
wondering if there's differing
evolutionary drives to perform behaviors
maybe it's more important
in an acute stage to be warm and so
there's a
drive to put more of your energies
toward having a good nest than
necessarily having a perfect hair coat
maybe it's relative discomfort
associated with the body posture
required to perform behavior so
in this case we did a laparotomy it
might be very difficult to assume the
upright posture and engage those
abdominal muscles when you've had a
laparotomy
maybe you might see something a little
bit different if the source of
discomfort will say a craniotomy
or a paw so perhaps
grooming transfer gets more to a dynamic
pain status which is
uh it hurts when i do this versus
more of a static pain status which is it
hurts all the time even when i'm sitting
still
so nest consolidation and grooming
transfer together might give us a really
nice
picture of both static and dynamic pain
acute early pain and more longer lasting
pain
only minor differences were noted when
we looked across all of our different
sources of variation
whether it was sex inbred outbread we
did notice that grooming transfer can be
used in socially housed mice
and that having an existing nest doesn't
interfere with the ability to assess
nest consolidation after surgery
when we look overall at our pain effects
again we're seeing
differences out to about 12 hours for
nest consolidation and out to about 48
hours with grooming transfer
so let's look at our analgesic drugs we
have our saline treated animals which
had
decreases in their nest consolidation
scores out through 12 hours
and when they were treated with uh
buprenorphine there was only a single
difference there
uh carprophen a slightly later time
point at four hours
happily with the multimodal treated
animals had both buprenorphine and
carpropin
we saw no delays and so we were able to
completely control for
pain associated decreases in nest
consolidation scores
when we look at grooming transfer scores
so sailing treated as an
a we can see that there were many time
points
2 and then 12 through 48 where we saw
decreases in grooming transfer with
saline treated animals
we saw slightly fewer with buprenorphine
although still present at 12
24 and 36 and carprophen about the same
as with saline
and multimodal about the same as with
buprenorphine so
still some room to improve analgesic
efficacy according to the grooming
transfer test
so looking across all the broad spectra
of different tests that we ran
with saline we had decreased body weight
at 24 and 48 hours so as a clinical
measure it was able to recognize
animals that underwent surgery but did
not receive any analgesics
for nest consolidation scores we saw
decreases at 2 4 8 and 12.
for grooming transfer we had decreases
in grooming behavior out through 48
hours
a single time point where unalleviated
pain resulted in a decrease in
mechanical threshold
and two time points at which local motor
activity was depressed
however if we had only looked at body
weight mechanical threshold and local
motor activity we would have missed some
really interesting changes
so for example with carbophene we're
able to see that there are
no decreases between those three
assessments
and there is some improvement in nest
consolidation because we only have a
decrease at one time point
and grooming transfer interestingly um
the only difference we really saw was
that
the pain appeared to be alleviated at 48
hours versus 36.
with buprenorphine we saw even fewer
differences between our surgery and
anesthesia group showing us that pain
was even more well controlled and with
multimodal
we had no differences in nested consol
nest consolidation
so it was like they had never had the
surgery and then grooming transfer we
saw
very few differences at those three time
points and again that's more of a
dynamic pain it hurts when i do this
so i think it's good that we're
controlling for that static pain which
is even if you're just resting
their pain levels were controlled
overall for analgesia efficacy
multimodal appeared to have
the best control of post laparotomy pain
and mice
followed by buprenorphine carprophen
which again was about 30 mix per keg
in the water uh was much delayed and
not nearly as good and then saline um
was only slightly better or slightly
worse than the carboprofen
for conclusions we were happy to find
that nest consolidation and grooming
transfer tests
appeared to be both valid measures for
post-op pain
they were fast easy to use can be used
cage side
and they can be used in a diverse array
of situations whether mice were
male female inbred outbred socially
housed singly housed
with or without an existing nest and so
hopefully can be applied to
the wide array of situations that you
find in your standard mouse liberia
multimodal analgesia appeared to have
the most efficacious post-op pain
although there was some partial coverage
noted with the grooming transfer test so
certainly it would be good to look into
this more and see if we could play
around with
different doses or some different
analgesics
carproof in the water unfortunately was
not sufficient as a single agent
analgesic
and this sort of falls in line with
other publications that have found
things
such as acetaminophen to be insufficient
for post laparotomy pain and mice
future directions we would love to be
able to um
titrate some of these to figure out if
there's a threshold for
treatment so if you see a score of x and
it should be y
that you should definitely pull the
trigger and provide some additional
analgesics
we'd like to be able to evaluate
additional analgesic regimens and see if
we can find more of a sweet spot
where we're able to control for pain
we'd like to look at other surgery sites
as i mentioned
the grooming transfer test in particular
it might depend on
where the site of the surgery or the
pain is so we did a laparotomy which is
pain
from the abdomen you might see something
very different if the source of pain is
the head or the paw or thoracotomy
meaning the chest wall it would be
really cool to see if this works with
other rodents such as rats because they
can also be really challenging to assess
post-op and it might have applications
beyond just looking at post-surgical
pain
it might be that we can use it to assess
end-of-life care decisions and human
endpoints
so with that i'd like to thank dr
vanessa oliver again who did
a large amount of this work and we could
not have been sharing these results
without her
our refinement and enrichment
advancements laboratory at the
university of michigan
with our lead technician sarah thurston
observers who helped us assess
these tests cage side jenny jones katie
simon dr kimberly jen
doctors lucy kennedy and dr sarah martin
and our funding
came generously from the grants for
laboratory animal science or glass
awards
um which are sponsored by alas as well
as dr bob disco in the unit for
laboratory animal medicine
and with that i'll take some questions
thank you dr lofgren for that
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question drop
down box located on the far
left of your presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on your screen
and click the send button once there as
many of your questions as we have time
for
now let's get started so our first
question is
dr lochran can you provide some
additional details on how you chose the
car profin water dose
yes thank you that's an excellent
question um we were definitely we're
looking to provide
some type of analgesic that wouldn't
require injections and i know delivering
analgesics in the water is something
that we often get asked about
and so this is something we decided to
explore um
we knew that from a publication in jlass
in 2013
they had already found that mice would
readily drink carpropin in the water
though not so for maloxicam there must
be something about the taste the mice
weren't keen on it but
they would readily drink the carproven
they actually tended to drink it
more than the water so we were pretty
enthusiastic that that might be a good
option
we then conducted a pilot study to
evaluate the 10 mg per kig dose that was
described in this j
last paper um and what we found
was uh here we have water consumption on
the y-axis
we have time on the x-axis regular water
consumption is in black
and in green is the carbon water so
these are the animals that
um would undergo surgery and drink
coffin water
and we found that the animals were just
as likely to be able to drink
the carproof and water in fact they
actually drank more of it
as compared to regular water at several
different time points
so at least that gave us full faith that
they would consume it after surgery um
and then we did pk analysis so we
collected blood spun it down for plasma
and sent it out to some of our
colleagues at the university of colorado
and what they found was the plasma
concentration remained
high the whole time that the animals
were on the carproof water so
they received it 24 hours as their
standard drinking water in a water
bottle
before they had any measures taken and
then time zero then
they had had it for 24 hours and we kept
the water bottle on for 48 hours
and we also pulled a sample at 72 hours
to see what would happen once you took
the car broken bottle
away and just gave them standard water
so you can see that the levels were up
around
30 micrograms per milliliter and based
on the literature
um that i think is derived from dogs
this was thought to be
an adequate efficacious um plasma
concentration for this drug
so we hypothesized that it was really
reaching therapeutic thresholds
but to test this we ran it through a
number of the same tests that i just
went through including mechanical
threshold nest consolidation and
grooming
and had some concerns so i'll discuss
those briefly um in that pilot test
where we provided the 10
10 migs per kg of carbon uh for nest
consolidation scores we found at
baseline they had scores of about four
between two and 24 hours um after
surgery those scores were significantly
depressed
for the first 12 hours and so we had
some concerns that analgesia wasn't
being met
when we looked at grooming transfer
scores here um you can see the black
line baseline
so um good grooming transfer scores and
reaching maximal by 24 to 36
hours but after surgery we had
significant delays
at several time points and so again had
some concerns that maybe analgesia
wasn't where we wanted it to be
and then when we did mechanical
thresholds with the von frey
we saw two time points at which there
was a decreased threshold
so the animals were more sensitive to
mechanical
stimuli after surgery than they were
after baseline
so even though they would readily drink
the 10 meg per keg
and we thought the therapeutic level had
been reached in the steady state
it didn't show the analgesia efficacy
that we were hoping for
and so we went into the literature again
and looked at some
other papers that had similarly been
disappointed with
carboprofin at standard doses and chose
a higher dose
30 minutes per keg to assess so these
are the volumes of mice sorry volumes of
carbon water
that were consumed by the mice on our
full study
and you can see here um the black bar is
the car profin
uh water the multimodal or the animal
side carproof and water
plus uh injections of buprenorphine so
um they were on par
and and readily drank the water in both
scenarios
and they had increases in water
consumption as compared to baseline so
again they were drinking it
more than they would drink their
standard water
we didn't see any differences in the
amount of water consumed
across any of our treatment groups or
whether or not they had had just
anesthesia
or they had had a surgery so they
weren't drinking more
say after having a painful condition and
self-treating
we did have some concerns when we
started looking at some of the blood
parameters
so not so much with
our cbc but more of their chemistry
we had some increases in creatinine and
ast
and i think that's because they were
actually consuming uh
potentially a higher dose than even the
30 per keg
because they really liked the water so i
think
caution is to be made when you're trying
to use
any sort of analgesic in the water and
that you need to make sure the animals
are consuming it
that published pk values are helpful but
don't necessarily
guarantee analgesia efficacy so it's
important not only to have the plasma
levels but also to do
the analgesia testing to make sure that
those plasma levels
correlate to reduced pain and then
with nsaids as it turned out with
carproof and if the mice really like
drinking coconut water
perhaps it tastes sweet they're going to
drink it and
potentially get a higher dose than you
intend them to and there might be
some possible sequelae for different
organ functions
and even at 30 minutes per cake we
didn't necessarily see the efficacy that
we wanted to see so
i think at this time i wouldn't
recommend carproof and water
as at least a soul analgesic but for
future directions it would be great to
look at
a lower dose and see if we could pair it
with
something like an opiate to have good
analgesia efficacy without the risk of
potentially having
some off-target effects thanks